He's a well accomplished computer
scientist entrepreneur and has held
several other academic and government
leadership positions. Known for his deep
engagement with students and his
dedication to improving their experience
on campus, Dr. Jahanian has already had
an enormous impact at CMU.
Good evening!
As one of the top institutions in the
world, we're a really hard-working place,
there's no question about that. But at
Carnegie Mellon, when we talk about work,
we mean something a little different.
We're actively engaged in work that matters.
We're at the forefront of bringing
people together from diverse backgrounds --
in science, in engineering, humanities,
public policy, business, the arts --
to address the pressing issues
facing society. We're positioned like no
other institution to define and manage
the space where technology and human life
intersect, and to train the next
generation to solve the problems of global significance.
This new era will be fueled by ideas, by breakthroughs
in new materials and digital technologies and robotics.
How do we contribute to this innovation economy?
Well, it's through the startups that have come
out of these universities. It's also
creating a entrepreneurial environment
where entrepreneurs and innovators want
to come to Pittsburgh and be here.
He had his hands in everything good at Carnegie
Mellon, and there is no question that in the few years
he has been a part ofthe Tartan family,
he has made lasting impacts to this institution.
I'm in awe of this community and all that it represents -- the passion, the ingenuity, the creativity and the pride.
Your passion fuels this great University.
You are Carnegie Mellon.